in january russian flags were waved on
the streets of the african nation
burkina faso after the country's
military leader overthrew the civilian
government with the military leaders
supporters chanting viva russia
[Music]
they also held signs like this which
read we demand cooperation with russia
france get out a few months earlier in
neighboring mali supporters of a
military coup there held pro-russian
signs featuring president vladimir
putin's face the takeovers are just some
of the latest in a surge of military
coups and attempted coups that have
rocked africa's sahel region and
unsettled global powers
if you take a look at this bar chart you
can see that africa has experienced more
coups in the past year than it has in
decades the head of the united nations
called it epidemic
the insurrections have caused
uncertainty and instability for the
millions of people now living under
military rule but they've also had major
international implications western
partners like france and the us have
withdrawn troops training and aid while
russian mercenaries have seized on the
instability to make money and advance
moscow's interests in the region
before we talk geopolitics it's
important to understand why these coups
are happening in the first place
many people in these countries are
facing violence from islamist groups
linked to al-qaeda isis and boko haram
not only have these groups been
expanding their targets in recent years
but they've also been seizing valuable
property and in some places taking over
local governments 2021 was a
particularly bad year violent incidents
in the sahel nearly doubled from the
year before and more than half of those
incidents occurred in burkina faso
and in some places citizens feel that
france the former colonial power has not
been a positive security partner
so what does the u.s have to do with all
of this for years american forces have
sent aid and hosted training exercises
to help african allies combat extremism
my colleague michael phillips has
observed some of these programs what are
they training them to do there are
different kinds of training to go on but
one that's particularly important
involves u.s special forces training
commando units from those african
nations
so it's sort of elite forces training
other elite forces this special forces
training known as flintlock is held in
west africa each year but in recent
months some of the african militaries
trained by the u.s have gone on to
overthrow their civilian governments in
coups that includes the military leader
who seized power in burkina faso the
insurrections haven't just alarmed
american partners they've actually
triggered laws that forbid the us from
providing assistance once the state
department declares that a coup has
taken place the u.s can no longer
provide military training military
equipment
money that sort of thing to the
militaries in those countries what have
american officials told you about this
american commanders will say well look
we're trying our best we're teaching
them what we think they should do i
think the u.s military genuinely hopes
these coups do not take place but once
they do this very little that can be
done
and that's where russia comes in russian
guns for hire are filling the void in
africa as western militaries pull back
they're making money gaining mining
concessions and helping moscow expand
its influence through the sale of
weapons and mercenary services much of
this is done through the wagner group a
shadowy military company that employs
former russian soldiers the kremlin
denies any formal ties with the wagner
group but western officials say wagner
acts as a proxy force for the russian
defense ministry and it's funded by this
man yevgeny pragozin an oligarch
commonly referred to as putin's chef a
team of researchers at the center for
strategic and international studies says
this satellite image of a wagner base
and a russian special forces base in
russia strongly suggests that the two
share training facilities wagner has
built other bases in countries where it
operates including the central african
republic and now these researchers say
wagner has built this suspected forward
operating base in mali right next to the
malian air force base mali's military
leaders hired the wagner group late last
year to provide security and western
officials say about 1 000 russian
mercenaries are now operating in the
country
that has led to a falling out between
mali and france and in february france
announced that it was withdrawing
thousands of troops who have been in the
country to fight extremism officials and
analysts say these wagner mercenaries
are useful to the military leaders
because they help them stay in power and
they spread disinformation to influence
public opinion there's been a lot of
rhetoric that mali is actually
liberating itself
from you know the throes of french
neo-colonialism
by pursuing a closer partnership with
russia now analysts fear that something
similar could happen in burkina faso and
other fragile african nations pushing
the west farther away and allowing
russia an opening to exert its influence
on the continent
[Music]
so what about the millions of people now
living under military rule in the sahel
their future looks far from certain
the resurgence of coup d'etats in our
region is a matter of grave concern
even though junta leaders look to russia
and the wagner group for security
western officials insist that the wagner
group makes countries poorer weaker and
less secure in some cases the wagner
group takes government money natural
resources and strategic land and it's
been accused of massacres and other
human rights abuses in africa
they're a malign influence they don't
follow anybody's rules
they do what they want they buttress
dictators
they violate
they do gross violations of human rights
i think it's bad for
africa's
security and prosperity in the future to
read more about russia's activity in
africa click the link i pinned below and
if you want to learn more about how
russia's actions in ukraine have
impacted nato check out this video thank
you for watching and i'll see you next
time